what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
um why divorce after 43 years of
marriage
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
this is especially um interesting to me
because i've you know been watching
manosphere content for months so it'll
be interesting to see if this video
lines up with what i've seen the
manosphere
on top of that my parents have been
married for 20 plus years so
it'll just be interesting to see why
she decided to get divorced
hi ladies hi viewers
this is palm springs cindy coming to you
tonight
uh from my kitchen as usual
and um i've had a lot i want to address
a few questions i've had
several people ask inquire
be curious about what
why i am having this life change
why i am having this life
transition at 70 years old
oh my god she's 70. i didn't know how
and i i kind of want to give a type of
answer to that only because
hold on a second
only because we're such a good friends
and my youtube sisters have followed me
for so long
and i'm sure that it's you know
inquiring minds want to know
and i'm not going to get into the
nitty-gritty of things
but i am going to say this
and then we're going to put it to rest
i was married for 43 years actually i'm
still
married my divorce is not quite final
and um above the 43 years
we dated two and a half years
so 43 45 43 44 45 so for 45 years
and a little more i have been with the
same man
and i he is a wonderful man
he has um been a wonderful
provider and
we have had a a very good marriage
for many many years i'm so confused and
why leave that's the dream
but people change
times change
circumstances change
and um i i i'm going to say
that
basically we drifted apart
and our lives became
more and more apart
the things he enjoyed the things he did
i didn't enjoy the things i
enjoyed the activities i did
he didn't enjoy and so
i'm hesitating with my words because i
don't
i want to say this in the right way with
respect to
him
i just know that i needed
my desires this what i wanted out of
life for the rest of my life i figured
maybe at 20 more years
was not what he wanted we both
wanted separate things and
we need to know what the separate things
are so different interests what i'm
thinking is maybe
one of them wanted to like travel the
world and one of them wanted to stay
i have one daughter who is an adult
she's
40 years old on her own
lovely wonderful so you know we don't
have
major anchors holding us down holding us
together
and so after careful consideration
i just thought
if i'm if i want to make a change
if i want to to pursue the life that i'm
dreaming about
then now is the time and so
i decided that i was going to seek a
divorce
and follow the path
that i wanted to follow it was not the
path
he chose to follow so
so basically to sum it all up
we just grew apart i've heard that a lot
like especially after kids
but people oh my gosh this stuff is so
scary i totally get why people fear
marriage
because that's 40 years and they chose
to walk away
we grew in separate ways we grew
in a different direction and
i i just made a decision that if i
wanted to live the life that i wanted
for the next 20 years then i needed to
make a break
i wonder if the manosphere sees this as
hypergamy
i'm not sure i see this as hypergamy and
that's what i that's what i did
we are still friends we are amicable
we um you know it's it's
good in that way so
that's really all i cared to say on the
subject
i will say dating after like my grandma
i stayed with her for a week and my
grandpa he passed away
but watching her and her friends like go
out
and like talk about how guys were cute
stuff was so weird
because they literally like acted like
teenagers
just like older i don't want to get any
more personal
than that but just know that
you know it all is well and we still
have our lovely daughter
that of course we're both uh connected
to
and um you know and and it's it's gonna
be okay
now am i sad that i have lost
my big beautiful home
no i'm not i lived there for 34 years
i loved every moment of it i enjoyed
decorating i
enjoyed entertaining i enjoyed the
holidays
all the above but it was time to move
on i needed to scale down
that was a burden on me that all the
things that we had collected for 34
years in that
house 43 years of marriage
i was just really um
i was carrying a weight that i wanted to
get rid of
regarding my home my possessions
and i needed to minimize honestly
i've always okay growing up in a giant
ass mansion
it's funny because i want a small house
because
you guys don't even know even with money
taking care of a house
this big is so hard because even if you
have money to hire people to take care
of it you still have to manage those
people
and i i've always said i want a small
i mean if i have kids like i'd be
obviously probably above average but
i don't want a lot of things i don't
want a super big house because it's too
much to take care of
and so that's what i've done it had it
has been a very hard two years
you have been with me my viewers every
step of the way
last january 26th is when i fell and
broke my knee
i was in a nursing home you were there
with me every step of the way
excuse me nope unintended
and um and so now i'm
here and uh i did
go out again tonight i wish i knew what
she meant
by that like what she meant by a
different interest in their vision
because what i think of is they want to
travel but
this is so bad a friend and we had a
lovely
evening we went to a beautiful
restaurant
and nice conversation
i i am um beginning to go
out i'm beginning to go out with
uh you know on dates
and it's very interesting
but i'm enjoying it you know it's who
wouldn't enjoy it
lovely dinner out who wouldn't enjoy
nice conversation i feel like she's
probably
does well dating even though she's older
because she looks so
young so the 70 year old guy is looking
to date
i don't know i would think she'd
probably be one of the better looking
like candidates who wouldn't enjoy
you know just anticipating and getting
dressed and
ready or whatever for um someone to pick
you up
on a date um it's very different
i'm not um you know
i'm i'm my mindset is
that if i do go on a date it's a date
it's it's an evening out or an afternoon
out
to enjoy someone's company to appreciate
a nice dinner
and that's it so you know i'm just
enjoying making new friends in my new
development
i'm enjoying my home and mostly this
week this next week
major things are happening you know like
i've said in my other videos
you know the painter is coming to paint
accent walls
the the cabinet makers are are coming to
put in the cabinets that they have made
the um light fixtures are going in
the window coverings are going in so a
lot will be happening to
make my house a home starting this week
and of course i couldn't be more
thrilled
so anyway i just got back from my date i
felt like
telling somebody about it and uh we went
to a restaurant that i had never been
to before and it was lovely we sat
outdoors
and they had outdoor heaters this is so
sad to me like how can you compare to
your husband to 40 years
because today is a really cold day here
in
the palm springs indio area it rained it
was windy
and so i actually wore my um
london fog coat over my dress tonight
but they did have those heaters over
every table
and you know it was fine we were we were
certainly comfortable
but um you know it was it's just
different
and i and i'm enjoying it you know like
like i said
70 so far has not been all that bad
i can't believe i'm saying 70.
so okay i'm home and i
am going to change my clothes get cozy
with shelby
and hopefully tune in something great on
netflix or amazon
but for all of you ladies out there who
are single
and ready to mingle i just want to say
that that's sort of where i'm at
and uh it's going to be okay
nothing permanent as far as you know
dating or men or anything like that
but certainly
certainly it's nice to be courted and to
be treated to a lot a lovely
evening out and like i said and
good conversation so
you know so that's all good right it's
it's good for me it's it's what it what
is this saying
she doesn't look like i don't know how
to put it but she does not
look actually happy to me it's all well
in my soul
so anyway i'm going to hang up and
hope hope that my mouth is in sync with
this video
p.s i love you and until our next
conversation let me see i was looking at
the comments
um okay you look i recently left my
marriage of 34 years i'm starting over
at 55 and it's okay follow your dreams
at any age
um i divorced my narcissistic husband
after 47 years best decision ever
oh come on you didn't know he was a
narcissist for 47 years
um i've thought about this video last
night and this morning i hope it works
out for you my husband died when i was
68 after 44 years i pulled up
my bootstraps and thought okay going to
move on i'm 75 now i have good genes and
i'm
and i'm and most think i'm early 60s i
dated a lot guys my age
we're looking for younger guys younger
for a sugar mama older
nurse or a purse i'm attractive fit and
fairly easy to get along with i can tell
you
it's been a bit it's been a very
disappointing
seven years i would give anything for my
companion back i heard the story
from other widows and i thought it would
be different for me i'm narcissistic
enough to think i'm special like i said
i hope it works out a different for you
just a reality check
the grass isn't always greener there's
always something
to say for a relationship that was solid
a man that would love you that's what my
thought was
and this is what so this is like a
little hint of honesty so to speak i'm
75 of good genes and most think i'm
early
60s guys my age we're looking for
younger younger looking for a sugar mama
um after my divorce at 52 i entered the
dating world and it was really nice i
went
i went in thinking i would just want
some companionship and i came out
with a beautiful man who's the kind of
sweetest man you'll ever meet we've been
together 10 years and
now i'm married for eight okay i'm sad
after 43 years
you left what in your words was a
wonderful man of course i do not know
the details that being said
let me say men at our age are out there
today are all rejects scammers and
widowers looking for a nurse with their
prayers best wishes i hope it's
different for you
yeah i don't know if i would have left
that
unless like it was so bad but
i don't know so
like stuff like that makes me so sad um
and i mean you don't necessarily know
the whole situation and that's why
sometimes i'm a little like not not too
quick to like
speak on whether i agree or i disagree
because it's her life you know it
doesn't affect me but
for i can't imagine dating is easier at
70 than it was
i wasn't even she got married let's see
she said she's 70 she's married
34 um so i know she said she dated for
two years
um 43 years of marriage so 70
minus 45 because that's two years so she
was 25 when she got married
damn well let me know in the comments
what you guys think of this video and
let me know what i should react to next
time
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys
next time